the Israeli militaries conducted
overnight raids in several neighborhoods
in the occupied West Bank this was the
scene in toam where Israeli forces have
surrounded the N Shams refugee camp
sealing off all the entrances troops
reportedly blew up the ground floor of
the home of a Palestinian man inside the
camp raids are also taking place in
betunia and tubas at least 40
Palestinians have been detained Imran
Khan is in the noan refugee camp in the
occupied West Bank 24 hours ago you were
talking to us from the Janine refugee
camp seen of many raids over the last
few weeks now you're at no Shams and
more raids
there that's absolutely right Nur Shams
is a camp that does get regularly uh
raided by the Israeli forces but this
one was a larger raid than perhaps we
seen in the last few weeks the Israeli
Army came in from all four entrances to
the camp north south east and west uh
they came down one this road uh that you
can see just now uh the raid came to an
end about 90 minutes ago 8:00 in the
morning but it began at 10:00 at night
uh there were about uh 40 uh armored
veic vehicles about 200 soldiers on foot
and armored bulldozers as well now what
we're being told is the Israelis were
going from house to house searching uh
for Fighters they did come uh under
heavy uh fire from Palestinian Fighters
were defending their homes but they did
destroy using those bulldozers um
mosques and homes now where you can see
that fire engine uh is actually the home
of the Palestinian you mentioned in the
introduction to me the earlier there was
a massive explosion the Israelis what
they did is they used incur grenades
they threw them into the house and that
actually uh made this huge explosion
there was a massive Billow of smoke
coming outside it was actually so big
that four other houses were actually uh
destroyed
as well now nobody's been arrested in
this particular raid but across the
occupied West Bank there have been uh
several arrests 30 in fact that brings
the number up to about
4,800 Palestinians have been arrested
since October the 7th over half of those
are in administrative uh detention uh
that means they're being held without
charge now here in nasham Camp people
are expecting further raids to take
place but given what's left here it's
difficult to understand you know what
the Israeli objective is here is it to
try and arrest people because they
didn't arrest anybody overnight or is it
simply a case of keeping the pressure up
on places like Janine refugee camp like
Nur Shams imman thank you very much
indeed Imran Khan in noam's refugee camp
in occupied West bik